ah j'ai un peu mal au coeur arrête
calme toi oh je vais prendre du grade
youtube se dit aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur un pacte avec un démon un
petit juin dès que j'ai encore trouvé
sur le net comme à chaque fois on se
retrouve sur ce jeu un et je veux le
dire deux fois je ne sais pas pourquoi
via le bouton options et marchent pas
histoire richard benjamin bratt marque
paul et antonio six hommes de
différentes époques médiévale seconde
guerre mondiale de nos jours et même du
futur on faire jour un pacte avec un
démon ob à baho zhu afin d'avoir les
choses qui désirent le plus au monde
serait studio de la mac do richard
voulait être riche huit semaines après
le pacte il eu un bon travail une belle
voiture une belle femme est une belle
maison il avait réussi sa vie
mais bientôt il comprendra que ces
cadeaux avaient été empoisonnés un jour
ou l'autre cette oeuvre doit mener sa
vie
l'histoire commence sur une route
lorsque richard de retourner chez lui
après son travail ça vous les invitant
au viera ça me plaît bien ap / espace
pour sauter introduction non content
supposément ébats cette route ya juste
deux lampadaires de manière totalement
par alessio ça a l'air cool sans
déconner voix se fait au moyen oient
parce que dans oi oui oui david nouilles
caisse le mec essayé d'envoyer du lourd
l'envoyé du très très lourd de la
voiture est complètement morte merde
fictivement cette problématique bombe a
envoyé par là bas qu'est ce qui existe
en droit on tombera dans droite rouge
une espèce de rituels de de sacrifice de
poulet là ça s'est un peu chelou la
presse le tap key to vu ces objectifs
atteste le scarabée géant de merde
j'aurais dû écraser au camping l'année
dernière 6 2 olalala glauque titude de
la chose c'est quoi ces des particules
de son qui vont annoncer les feuilles
des plantes et des arbres trois hommes
jean vêtu un dangereux psychopathe est
souvent faite j'accroche des décors en
haut des arbres et du coup ils plus des
gouttes de sang voilà bon jean françois
qui est énorme psychopathe depuis 1930
eh ben on va rester sur ce petit coin de
lumière maman ma maman viens m'aider
puisque c'est comme ça je mets en
position foetale bon à et on les connaît
on doit trouver un objet démoniaque un
lampadaire séméga démoniaque à
lampadaires [ __ ] je n'aurais jamais dû
prendre ce chemin je suis en train de me
perdre
what an qu'est ce que c'est que ça on
dirait une sorte de kebab vivant
regarder car à mon chou
non sans déconner l'ag taf rock et zapf
à quetta ya eu un bruit flippant mais
alors à l'écran il n'y avait absolument
rien on est d'accord il s'est absolument
rien passé a les crocs pourquoi il ya ce
bruit comme sarah qui se succèdent chose
c'est bien une sorte d'elvis presley
avec un pot d'échappement coller à la
nuque mortels cette porte est fausse
bombe à tiques pour ta maison tu as fait
importe invisible voilà ou alors si tu
préfères si jamais été pressé que tu
arrives par l'autre côté de la maison tu
peux éventuellement passer par le bureau
voilà très bien donc il nous faut du
sang une potion de sang rouge
un homme la tête de la statue d'un démon
une épée démoniaque un livre et un
squelette
alors est-ce que la statue du démon
c'est pas le elvis presley avec le pot
d'échappement dans la nuque qui
attendait en baisse et noir way we get
yes yes we can gros problème et qui
trouve un truc dangereux et on peut plus
de sa vie qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
quoi à eux je m'en vais lâche moi laisse
moi qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
l'homme garde ou encore l'homme grecque
oui comment ça va fais moi
oh non mais tout ça parce que j'aime pas
ça qu on va zitter bhavan t3i n'importe
quoi alors on va continuer tout droit
alors normand j'ai lu que on doit ce
guide et paula on a vu une feuille qui
nous a fait un gros qu on doit se guider
par rapport au ciel alors comment cela
est il possible étant donné c'était
peut-être pas ce jeu là en fait
bon voilà on se tape un peu les fesses à
metz ah je sais pas si c'est un os c'est
peut-être un coton-tige y en aa sud
bon allez on repart de recherche assez
l'araignée on prend la hausse et on s'en
va mais elle est carrément dégueulasse
quand tu leur fais un mois c'était bien
et des mois le courrier j'avais entendu
s'il vous plaît au teint j'appuie sur
contrôle gauche pour mme besset et c'est
la touche pour quitter le jeu
ajoutons maintenant retrouver dos merde
à les plombs tous ensemble pour cette
grosse erreur chatte yeux - tafer mois
avec un bateau allez on y retourne à
merde déjà sa place je serais resté dans
la voiture pourrait verrouiller les
portes et j'aurais fait à abobo on
attend qu'il fasse jour à parce que je
suis qu'une grosse tempête c'est que ce
bruit on aurait dit un mec qui faisait
une crise d'épilepsie dans les bois quoi
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu veux des
acheteurs amène un grec dalle je vais
chercher l'homme grec là bas on dirait
une sorte de mikado géant ce lampadaire
vous trouvez pas à un nouveau bâtiment s
quoi peut-être trouvé de l'épée des
moyens qu'il a un cancer qu'est ce qui
se passe qu'est ce qui se passe quoi
quoi quoi et comment ça va où il allait
un peu stocks comme le mec il a l'air un
peu beaucoup musclé je propose pour son
adieu la sépaq avec mes bras qui font un
centimètre de large on va pas trop
points se défend en fait mais si si à
moins que je trouve les pélémois iec au
jeu fois que la lumière lapin ou ça sans
ça ce sont les [ __ ] mosnac là j'aurai
une meilleure épais que cet homme un sur
ce jeu au all à pau sio la potion de sel
rouge c'était le crâne d'un homme plutôt
immense
je veux les plus démoniaques et
maastricht et les bb brunes y ait
réservé je veux lipides démoniaque
bordel on a compté des épées en
plastique du parc astérix là il y en a
qu'on est et pedro main lie en a qu'ont
les épées démoniaque 1
alors même si elle est en mousse je veux
qu'elle soit démoniaque bordel de merde
oui j'ai un problème
oh mon dieu qui nous manque plus que
l'épée démoniaque
c'est le plus beau jour de toute ma vie
ah je crois qu'à à une araignée il est
temps de nous attaquer vite je prend la
fuite sacha pikachu chez moi au nom un
black man se joindre à elle
zut et vont faire des bébés araignées
zizi noir à n'auriez pas vous vu une
certaine les pélémois diack à je
trouverai jamais cette foutue ep
démoniaque jaune à voile a choisi